ils peuvent constater effectivement la
résilience russe qui a décidé que quoi
qu'il arrive aujourd'hui a été dans une
guerre avec l'ukraine et que même les
sanctions ne la font pas faiblir pour
l'instant du moins
ensuite il faut qu'ils voient quelles
sont les capacités qu'ils ont à
accepter la situation
vis-à-vis de vladimir poutine la
problématique du pétrole est
fondamentale est-ce qu'on va passer
cette étape là c'est à dire se priver de
pétrole c'est très compliqué pour les
européens donc est-ce qu'on est quand
même capable de le faire ça reste un
levier qu'on a sur un plat d'ymir
poutine l'autre question qui est
fondamentale c'est la reconstruction
d'ukraine s'est un peu trop tôt pour en
parler mais l'union européenne a déjà
dit qu'il y aurait un fonds fiduciaire
dead pour la reconstruction et l'union
européenne et puis le dernier point vous
l'avez évoqué elisabeth c'est évidemment
de parler des civils qui sont
aujourd'hui la préoccupation numéro une
de l'europe des états unis et de tout le
monde d'ailleurs mais comment est ce
qu'on arrive à mettre ces corridors
humanitaires pour que les civils
puissent s'en aller situation
extrêmement difficile puisque les les
russes sont en plein bombardement et
lorsque les russes bombarde ce dont ils
ont peur eux c'est que l'or dans les
corridors humanitaires il ya des
combattants qu'ils s'en aillent c'est
pour ça qu'en règle générale dans ce
genre de moment c'est quasiment
impossible d'arriver à trouver une
traque une chaudière à une capacité
pacifique en fait d'opérer